what would a British Christmas dinner be
without roast turkey while it would
still be Christmas dinner
Turkey's dominance of our festive table
is concertedly recent and for much of
the last 500 years it was the meat of
choice turkeys are native to Central
America where they were domesticated
around 200 BC by the time Columbus and
his fellow explorers started to discover
the delights of indigenous foods they
were eaten far beyond their original
picking grounds and it spread to North
America in the Caribbean from there the
spread of turkey was spectacular by 1511
every ship leaving the Americas for
Spain was ordered to bring back five
breeding pairs by the 1530s they were
being farmed in France and in England in
1541 they were restricted by law along
with cranes and swans - only one such
bird being served per feast it's not
clear exactly where the British got
turkeys from they were imported from
America but they also came in via Turkey
hence the name they were large versatile
and most importantly visually impressive
after all another competitor was the
peacock turkeys apparently taste better
a popular way to serve them was in a
raised pie with the tail wings and head
and neck cooked onto skewers and put
back in the pie resplendent a gazing
back at that would be diner turkeys were
not just for Christmas they were eaten
throughout the winter fowl was as its
best for September to March inevitably a
big juicy expensive bird in season in
December became associated with the
feasting which went on for 12 days from
the 25th by the 17th century turkey was
well-established as one of the key
Christmas meats in America the early
settlers were saved from starvation by
Native Americans who shared their food
in 1621 the first recorded Thanksgiving
feast took place turkey was eaten and it
became an established part of the
various Thanksgiving celebrations which
were held over the next 200 years later
Thanksgiving was declared a national
holiday with turkey at center stage by
the 19th century in Britain turkey was
very much still a Christmas dish but not
the main one if you were rich you had
lots of other meats and beef was still
the manes day if you a porter he was
unaffordable you might have a cheaper
goose instead that said in 1861 the
quintessential middle-class writer in
some time plagiarist Isabella Beaton
declared that a Christmas dinner with
the middle classes of this Empire would
scarcely be a Christmas dinner without
its
icky things didn't really change until
the second half of the 20th century when
after two world wars and a depression
mules were rather smaller even for the
rich and feast centered on one meeting
most in the 1950s America cast a
glamorous pall over British food and as
we greedily embraced images of golden
Thanksgiving turkeys we turned to them
more and more for our own festive fare
even if your oven was too small helped
was a hand well into the sixties the
local Baker's would open on Christmas
morning their ovens ready for the locals
Christmas roast now our image of the
ideal Christmas dinner is focused on the
turkey but there are voices of dissent
it's dry it's over bread and we can do
better they whisper and they may have a
point
after all turkey can apparently be a
lovely thing but if we really liked it
wouldn't we cook it more than once a
year
you